all right good morning everyone
all right there's two more people wow
what a crowd
good morning okay
let's take this off
sure
it's off consent
yes ma'am that's the first item
I think
education oh yes it's this one okay
all right we will take that one off
all right
um
Let's see we have some people missing so
representative Broda can sit in for
representative hatch
representative fellows for Senator
chandley and represent hacken Phillips
for Senator Whitley would be the way to
do it
and on the minutes I believe there's a
correction
yes
um
on item five on the
proposed minutes
um we staff overlooked the fact that uh
this was Final proposals 2022 229 from
HHS about the immunization registry
rules uh representative Leon had
requested that the agency amend its
religious exemption form by removing the
phrase requests for a that was to
clarify that the religious exemption is
a right and does not require a request
Senator Lang included that change in his
conditional approval
and that was approved by the committee
and the department did make the change
on its form
excellent thank you does someone have a
motion on the minutes move to approve as
amended second
any other additions Corrections or
comments
and seeing none
to approve already moved
you seconded representative
those in favor
aye aye any opposed all right thank you
very much and Senator Greg welcome you
can sit in for Senator Ward who I don't
believe is here
thank you
okay so we have a Full Slate amazing
consent
representative oh actually let me
rephrase
we want to pull something off correct
yes you move you move to approve consent
and representative fellows has moved to
take off item G
h
is there a second to approve consent
okay on and the discussion on consent or
any other items to come off
seeing none of those in favor
aye aye opposed
right
on to the regular agenda and Department
of Education
and we will cover that item off consent
at the same time just to save you the
trouble
so for 2022
1 the comprehensive agricultural
Educators the reason this is on the
regular agenda is because the department
or excuse me the board is repealing the
certification based on the
recommendations from the Professional
Standards Board
the recommendation was based on the low
number of Educators that currently work
in this field and hold the certification
upon looking upon the agency's website
there were only two people listed who
had the certification
so it was placed on the agenda in case
the committee had any questions about
why that certification was being
repealed and what will happen to those
two individuals
Everson Broda
so I would imagine that this um went
through the regular public meetings and
so people are aware that we're doing
that as well as the two people are
certified
yes the agency is nodding vigorously
would you introduce yourself please
Julie Shea administrative rules
coordinator for Department of Ed
Steve Appleby division director
Department of Education
I presume that the two certified people
will continue to be employed because we
haven't taken their skills away just a
piece of paper
that is correct okay any other questions
representative fellows
um
I looked on the
certification database
and
I found
that there were seven people with that
certification that are employed
thank you for the question
um
there are however many of the
individuals hold other endorsements
and this endorsement is actually
redundant to the career and tech ed
agriculture endorsement so all of these
folks qualify
at no cost to them for the comprehensive
for the
CTE agriculture endorsement follow-up
follow-up please
so when I looked on the certification
database I found only two people
certified with the general agricultural
um educator and when I and
comprehensive agricultural educator is a
different endorsement yeah so
essentially we're combining these two
endorsements because they're their
requirements are identical with one
exception that is the degree requirement
the degree requirement for the non-cte
which is comprehensive agriculture this
rule set that degree requirement is a
bachelor's degree the career in tech ed
endorsement does not have that
bachelor's degree requirement but the
competencies and expectations are
substantially the same
so what you're following yes so
essentially what you're doing is you're
repealing
um the general agricultural endorsement
we're repealing the comprehensive
agriculture endorsement
I I think that there's um some sort of
confusion here because there are seven
people with that endorsement that are
employed and only one of them one of
those seven
has
another endorsement that's related to
Agriculture and that would be animal
s science or some kind of animals things
so I think that
there's
a confusion here
so the the State Board is repealing the
comprehensive agriculture endorsement
whether it's two people hold it or seven
really doesn't ultimately matter
everyone who holds it has been notified
via email and we have in contact with
them and they will automatically be
eligible for the career and tech ed
agriculture endorsement
by nature of holding currently comp
agriculture so we're essentially again
collapsing two separate endorsements
with the same requirements into one so
what are those two endorsements one is
comprehensive agriculture educator and
or teacher and the other one is the CTE
agriculture
and then under that CT agriculture there
are some sub endorsements like animal
science those types of things
okay thank you so so this has been
approved by the Board of Ed of Education
it's had the proper comment and none of
the and
were essentially transitioning
agricultural teaching from the general
education pool into the CTE pool is that
correct that is correct
not sure I agree with that people ought
to know about agriculture everywhere but
that's not my decision to make
any other questions or comments
representative Lynn yeah so I I guess I
want to make sure that I'm understanding
you say that the the the the one
the position that these people the two
people will be transitioned into
does not require a bachelor's degree is
that correct
correct so we have two endorsements
today both agriculture right one
requires a bachelor's degree which that
person
um there were only several of them
Statewide and that teach in a non-cte
center under that endorsement those
folks this does not affect their ability
to do the job as the chair pointed out
this is just right what license they
hold and so those folks can then
they qualify automatically for the CTE
agriculture endorsement if they want to
maintain licensure and that would allow
them to continue
right I guess the only thing I'm
concerned I'm concerned about is is the
effect of this that we're sort of
lowering the standards that are required
for
um
people that teach in this area in other
words now
at least for some of some of what
of of the people that previously were
required to have bachelor's degrees now
they don't and I'm just wondering if
that in effect is a lowering of the
standards
I don't I won't speak for the state
board but that wasn't their feeling
we have a situation right now in one of
our districts where CT centers across
the parking lot from a high school
and
they teach the same agriculture class
across the parking lot from each other
but one has our higher requirement for
licensure than the other but it's the
same class
so the State Board felt that that didn't
make a lot of sense
I presume that all all teachers regard
regardless of their certification do
have a bachelor's degree in something
I'm not in our CTE centers ah
they may have Hands-On experiences dad
representative Broda
so I'm going to Echo um
representative Lynn's concern in that
because there are two high schools with
similar programs that high school is not
going to issue a bachelor's right it's
just going to issue a high school
diploma so you're talking about two
similar tracks
so I can understand how the CTE program
comes into play but I don't understand
repealing a bachelor's program it's not
a bachelor's purpose did you say yeah
the teacher must have a bachelor's
presumably in agriculture I'm sorry when
you say ba it confused me okay thank you
I apologize so would it be fair to
assume that the high schools that
currently have agricultural programs
May eliminate them in favor of sending
people to the CTE or do or are they able
to continue teaching them with teachers
without a specific agricultural
certification yes in fact this should
actually allow more high schools to add
agriculture programs
because they will the requirements for
agriculture teacher were much higher
than the CTE requirements right so that
held back some high schools it's our
understanding from offering agricultural
programs because they couldn't get a
licensed teacher in this area
thank you all right
oh I'm sorry
so can can you look up
the um two endorsements that you're
talking about because you're I just
um think that it's not clear which one
you're eliminating
I mean I don't know by looking at
507.04 and
I don't know what is the other one thank
you madam chair so again on on the
packet that was given us on 20 on 22 221
right onto 6A it says the board of
education is proposing the repeal of Ed
507.04 on the certification of
comprehensive agriculture
um educator so I I think it's clear what
they're eliminating I think the idea
that if I understand the agency correct
is that all they're doing is folding
this comprehensive certification into
the CTE certification so that either in
high school or a CTE Center a teacher
that holds a CTE certification can teach
in both environments
okay representative Lynch so I guess I'm
I'm I'm still not clear on this this
aspect of it in other words why
and and please understand I I certainly
don't suggest that you that you you know
that that there shouldn't be some
grandfather provision for people who are
currently teaching and don't have a
degree but I I guess I'm not I mean why
is it that you've decided to that the
way to handle this is to eliminate the
bachelor's uh requirement for these two
teachers as opposed to saying we're
going to require a bachelor's degree for
everybody that teaches in this area and
we will we will grandfather the people
that don't have it for now but going
forward I mean it does sort of seem that
that you really are lowering the
standards you're saying that the
bachelor's degree is not important for
this teaching so
um just for a little background on the
process of how these rules land here uh
the first thing that occurs is the
Professional Standards Board forms a
committee typically several years prior
to expiration of any Rule and the
Professional Standards Board is made up
of Educators from our public system
superintendents teachers other
practitioners and they conducted their
subcommittee conducted a study
um they looked at what other states do
they surveyed folks from the field and
then they combined all that into a
recommendation to the state board and
their recommendation was the repeal of
this endorsement and just going with the
CTE endorsement
the State Board then held their normal
course of meetings had public hearing I
don't believe we received any comment
regarding the repeal at the State Board
and at that point the State Board
unanimously passed as the PSP had done
repealing this and just using the CTE
endorsement moving forward so
um And to clarify the numbers the CTE
General agriculture endorsement there
are two individuals the comprehensive
agriculture there are seven individuals
those seven will get the CTE agriculture
endorsement moving forward they will not
need to have it to teach in a non-cte
high school because this will become a
non-credentialed role in those high
schools
the local superintendent can still
require the individual to hold a
bachelor's degree in order to hire them
it just means that to get the CTE
agriculture endorsement
they will no longer have that degree
requirement but but there is quite a
process to this over several years and a
lot of it comes from the field itself
so we did hear superintendents that feel
that there is a barrier to them offering
agriculture classes because many folks
from that field
similar to what whether it's an auto
mechanic or a welder don't tend to have
bachelor's degrees
thank you thank you Senator Lang so
again I just as well we're just proving
the rule here just as a statement of
comment is that many businesses
including the state of New Hampshire
state of Maryland are removing Bachelor
degrees from job specific positions
things like I.T and things like
agriculture things where we have degrees
were required they're now substituting
experience on a regular basis in the
workforce that we're in and so I don't
think this is an uncommon move in in in
Industry right now those in teachers is
why we have CTE programs again CD
programs use people are experts in their
field but may not necessarily have a
degree and they're just as capable of
teaching the expert topic that they're
talking about so I I don't see a problem
with doing this I think it's a good move
for us especially in the labor market
that we're in
one more comment
that that explanation makes sense but
when I hear that there are only two
people in the program from you from your
testimony I know that the two the
certification that has two employees is
called General Agriculture and not
comprehensive agriculture which has
seven people certified and when I looked
up
people working
in a school district with with an
either General agricultural con
comprehensive agricultural animal
science or Horticulture I came up with
23 people and this is impacting seven of
23 which is significant and I just the
fact that you tell tell me that there's
only two people in this program and it's
just concerning can I just clarify for
the record that the number two first
came from OLS not from my testimony
thank you we're we appreciate your
saying that you know how many people are
in which category of certification chair
move to a proof is there a second okay
okay thank you second by by Senator
Ennis and any further discussion
those in favor
aye opposed
hey thank you let's go on to the uh
what is it the comprehensive business
educator which was taken off consent are
there any uh
comments on that
um no I had no comments on this it was
consent um they are essentially
repealing a section and then re-adopting
it with amendments
um so you'll see a bunch at the top text
that's been crossed out and then
Rewritten below it
so what's the use the essence of the
change
um it looks like they're renumbering
um
secretly outlined
the re-aducted okay the relevant
requirements have been absorbed as
amendments in the newly amended 507 49
making 507.48 no longer necessary
okay thank you that seems pretty clear
any questions from the committee
representative fellows
um I'd like if you could give us a
better explanation of this so I looked
at
um certificate people excuse me
representative fellows if since you've
asked them for an explanation perhaps
they could take it from there
okay we'll start with that okay
thank you for the question
representative
um so we had a marketing endorsement and
a business endorsement and what the
state board is doing is combining them
into one endorsement
so taking the competencies of marketing
which was held by very few folks
and folding those into the
the uh
requirements for business and moving
forward with one endorsement instead of
two separate ones so the essence is that
all people teaching
have some competencies in marketing so
the comprehensive business educator
already had some elements of marketing
in it and what the PSB did is they took
the comprehensive marketing educator
took some of those other pieces that
weren't included in the business
educator originally and then they moved
those under the business educator so
that the marketing piece was a little
bit more robust and now all of those
folks that hold the comprehensive
business have a little bit more of a
marketing requirement just because they
have all of those different elements
involved versus just the very specific
marketing educator
thank you that makes sense to me
um just speaking as a marketing
professor at UNH
um I'm pretty comfortable with this
change thank you
and I would have to say that with my
experience with small businesses in
particular having everybody learn
something about marketing is very
important
representative fellows
um
don't I one of the reasons I thought
would it made sense to have a separate
marketing is that that's a very
um
well
subscribed major for college students so
I wonder if this has any impact on the
dual enrollment program or I don't know
if you still call it
um
what is it like there's another burning
star another program that used to have
where they could get um credit for the
running Start program
I am not aware of any impact but I'm
also not I'm I can't answer either way
to that question
okay questions move to approve
second okay
any further discussion
all right seeing none those in favor I
opposed
all right
professional education requirements
Madam chairman yes was the second on
that representative Schmidt yes thank
you
okay for item 2023-10
um this is on the
professional education requirements for
each graduate of a professional educator
preparation program the reason this is
on the regular agenda is because these
rules had expired on December 17th of
2021 so these rules are now currently
being adopted
for shame
what you have to say about that please
so this rule set points to our
corresponding set of rules in the Ed
500s
so there
many of our ed600 rules we're going to
be back before you month after month in
the future because we're going to
instead of having all this voluminous
text in the ed600s that is identical to
the ed500s we're merely going to change
wording to point to the corresponding
500. so the 500s were in place never
expired and those are requirement of
licensure
so having this expire had no net effect
on our licensure operation because the
500s were still in effect
that's not a good reason why it expired
I'm just saying that's
it any other questions or comments
move to approve
any further discussion
those in favor
aye
those opposed
all right
hey thank you very much and I think
that's thank you
right
um
acquired brain disorder services in the
community okay
I'm so uh staff has no comments on 2022
um it was well in case we'd like to hear
from
Stephanie Patnick
good morning
good morning thank you so much for
hearing my comments my name is Stephanie
Patrick I'm from disability rights
Center and I wanted to talk to you about
the Hem 310s we did send a letter to the
committee earlier this week expressing
our concerns
um so hopefully you receive that it is
much more eloquently describes these
issues than I will today I'm sure but
I'm hopefully you have that I did bring
some copies so if you didn't see it let
me know I'm happy to to pass some of
those around I'm not sure if I have
enough for everyone yeah I did not
actually receive that
um so I would like a coffee if oh you
didn't okay
I didn't get it
yeah
send it on Wednesday my email I'm sorry
our office has been having internet
problems lately so I'm sorry
all right
so rather than reading your letter if
you could summarize the important
comments and concerns
I would be happy to do that
so um disability rights Center the goal
of our agency is to protect the rights
of people with disabilities across New
Hampshire and we have been having
conversations with the Department of
Health and Human Services over the past
I would say a year almost about this
rule
um and so we we've made some progress
but we do have significant concerns
still with the proposed Rule and whether
it complies with federal law
whether it what whether it complies with
federal law
so the federal law in the center for
Medicare and Medicaid services makes it
clear and this is all about tenant
protections for people who live in group
homes let's give you the context of this
it's the ATM 310s protect the rights of
people with developmental disabilities
and um they provide an overview of the
rights the the major proposed change
that we are concerned about are the the
rights of tenants
so back in 2014 the federal government
passed a law and rules called the HCBS
settings rule and what it says is that
if
people who live in group homes don't
have the same rights as tenants who live
in apartments in New Hampshire the state
is required to provide comparable rights
so it says for settings in which
landlord tenant laws do not apply which
we believe they don't apply in these
settings based on New Hampshire's law
because there are exceptions for people
in group homes
um the state must ensure that a lease
residency agreement or other form of
written agreement will be in place for
each HCBS participant and that the
document provides protections that
address eviction processes and appeals
comparable to those provided under the
jurisdictions landlord tenant laws
and so um the letter just explains what
our concerns are
the first one is that you have to have a
notice when you whenever you're given a
notice to be evicted that you're going
to be evicted and it has to be very
clear that it is not in order to vacate
that you if you appeal the evictions
procedure you all know this I'm sure
much better than I do in terms of
evictions if you appeal that eviction
you are allowed to stay in that place
while the eviction is going through the
process
and so the notice needs to be very clear
on that the second is that the the rules
around that are proposed around actually
appealing that of fiction do not make it
clear that the person is allowed to stay
during that process and we feel like
this is critical because it's also not
clear
otherwise how someone would be able to
dispute whether they meet the criteria
specifically if the landlord alleges
that their behavior would adversely
affect the health or safety of other
tenants or that the tenant has called
has called substantial damage to the
premises and I will say that in in our
work representing people with
disabilities we often have to hear
disputes about that a provider who
perhaps says that one one threatening
statement from a person with a
disability which is related to their
disability these are behaviors that
they're working on
um would would cause that level of
threat and so we feel like it's critical
that a person with a disability would
actually be able to stay during the
eviction process and be able to go in
front of a judge and say I don't believe
that my behavior met the standard for
evictions within the 72-hour notice
um it's critical that the person is able
to engage in the discovery process to be
able to provide their evidence that they
are addressing these behaviors and that
they are um that they have an impartial
person who can hear that because
otherwise it's just up to I guess the
provider the area agency it's not
exactly clear within the role so like I
said I sent you a very much more
eloquent letter that explained those
concerns hopefully you have none now but
we we do not believe that the the
proposed rule provides sufficient
protections for people with disabilities
who um who have been alleged to be
engaged in these behaviors and um are
appealing that that decision by the
provider
okay thank you that appears to
demonstrate your concerns does the
agency have a position
well we first do we have any questions
no I think you made your point where
very clearly and we'd like to hear from
the agency on why they uh what they're
doing about it thank you
good morning my name is Melissa Nemeth I
am the attorney for the Bureau of
Developmental services
uh good morning Allison radmay
administrator for the administrative
rules unit for the Department of Health
and Human Services
so uh as as Stephanie pointed out this
is a The Residency agreement is newly
something that we're adding to the rule
in order to comply with Federal
Regulations
um and it does say that individuals need
to have rights comparable to individuals
what they would have under the landlord
tenant law the Department's position is
that the what we have in the rule and
The Residency agreement that is attached
meets the requirements of the of giving
notice I'm looking at on the on the
final proposal it's page 20.
um letter C provides information about
if the provider is choosing to end the
residency agreement in in number one
these the standard if there's not a
behavior that is alleged to be an
immediate safety concern is that the
notification will be provided 90 days
before the proposed termination date and
they highlight the word proposed as I
think that gets to the question about
that is not a you're not moving out on
that day that's we're proposing to end
sort of like an eviction when you get a
notice we're proposing to end your
tenancy on X date so we have that
provided in in number one okay
does that make sense to the committee
that representative Hawkin Phillips yes
thank you madam chair so as an attorney
who used to practice landlord tenant law
in the state of New Hampshire I can
assure um the department as well as the
committee here that there are notice
requirements in eviction
um proceedings the actual service that
requires that special notification that
this you know there's a there's a
Verbatim verbiage that you have to
include on the original notices that
talk about this is not your day of
leaving this is your ability to appeal
the process and to apply with the court
to defeat this eviction so I mean there
there are specific protections under RSA
540 and throughout that long landlord
chapter that assures that verbiage is
already included on any eviction notice
so
um I think that the concern is important
on behalf of the woman who gave
testimony earlier but I think that our
rsas already do have those protections
built in except if that RSA does not
necessarily apply to someone living in a
group home
no
um I don't think that is correct I think
the RSA for any evictions
do fall under RSA 540. um that's our
understanding is that the landlord
tenant law exempts these um in RSA 540
it says facilities that are licensed
under RSA 151 are certified under RSA
126a and those are the types of
locations that we're talking about so
that's why we're building that into the
rule but getting back to our in the rule
here in number six is language about if
the resident fails to vacate the
residents by the termination date then
the provider gives that notice and get
that would give them the ability to
appeal so they get the original notice
it would be 90 days in the ordinary
course or if there were significant
concerns about someone's Behavior
causing safety concerns to themselves or
others it would be a 72-hour notice but
in either case if the individual does
not vacate the premises by that proposed
termination date then they get a notice
um to vacate within three days and then
that's what they are able to appeal and
um because the landlord tenant laws
don't apply and this these are overseen
by the the department it would be to the
Department's administrative Appeals Unit
that these hearings
um where that would fall so we feel like
the information included here and the
requirements for the notice are
sufficient to meet the needs and give
appropriate notice to folks and they
would to the concern about you know
there was a something raised about the
discovery process and information they
would be allowed to provide the there is
another set of rules
um HEC 200 that govern the
administrative appeals process and in
that process IT addresses the exchange
of Discovery materials so the department
didn't feel it was
needed to include that here in this rule
because this is just your your rights
and if it falls into that appeal process
then those rules would be invoked and
that process would be followed
follower just a quick follow-up could
you cite the RSA for the group home
so that where I was looking was RSA 540
colon one in definitions of actions
against tenants sure
um and it gives it gives the exemptions
under Roman numeral four and it's letter
C great there thank you you're welcome
representative
so I think the woman who spoke before
you her concern was that these
conditions would not have would not or
might not be properly identified to
those individuals living in these
facilities so how do these what you
shared with us
um
prove otherwise
or demonstrate otherwise
so
there they would be able to appeal that
if they if they were they got a 72-hour
notice to leave and we gave the
expedited time frame which is attracts
to landlord tenant live someone's
behavior is dangerous then but again if
they don't move out then they get the
right to appeal and that's when they
could raise the through that appeals
process is where they could challenge
that they didn't feel that that reason
for them being provided that notice was
appropriate would it be reasonable to
ask you to include the explicit language
for that on any written notice that they
receive because I can imagine that
someone who receives such a notice
might not be interested in Wading
through layers of laws and rules to find
their uh their rights
so they're going to have attached to the
rule is the residency agreement that
they they sign when they move in here
and there is a section in there that
points to that includes all of these
Provisions that I've talked about in the
rule they're Incorporated in this form
as well
okay but but what I I'm specifically
asking if you're handing somebody a
notice that you have to find a new place
to live in 90 days you should explicitly
give them what they can do about it
if they don't agree with the decision
especially the the appeal aspect I think
otherwise you're you're I mean I agree
with the chair entirely it may be
explicitly stated earlier in that
document but I I think if you're going
to be giving them that notice and you
have to inform them as well that they
have the right to appeal right there so
they don't have to dig around through
their contract to find it exactly
because I was particularly somebody
who's been there for a while probably
can't find their contract
foreign so this one again on on what
page around page 20 of the rule on under
number six it specifically says I mean
besides first they give them 90 days to
notice and then it looks like if they
don't move out
um there they give that 72-hour notice
and included as requirement included on
that notice that 72-hour notice that
they must leave it says it includes the
rights of the residents to an appeal and
the notice in accordance with the appeal
process that's listed below and then the
appeal process has all the other
conditions so I think we're giving
notice across the board you know even at
the last minute when the person still
hasn't moved out we're saying oh by the
way you have to get out and here's your
appeal process if you disagree with us
and they're telling them that in the
notice requirement at least according to
the rule
yes
reps on Broda so my concern is that
these are individuals that have special
needs they're there for a special reason
and they get this eviction notice right
what if I mean if I were I would imagine
that I would be very uncomfortable with
that
and then you know do I stick it under my
bed do I you know hide it do I pretend
it didn't happen I mean what record it
says that you can call and it says you
can have a
a right to a team meeting and maybe that
is the protocol but I just feel as if
three days you know within 90 day with a
three-day
um eviction notice then to get the
appeal notice seems to me a little bit
too late so I think that we should
outline those things off at the very
beginning so that these individuals who
are challenged in ways that we do not
know
are
given that help yes and since you
already have that information of what
what the appeals process is
just attack make sure reference it in C1
you know provide the notice in writing
you know and make sure that said notice
includes the
the appeal process and the rights of the
tenant it's Madam chair are we talking
number one on the 90-day notice just
including the appeal process in that
90-day notice I mean understand the
90-day notice is the resident the legal
guardian and the service coordinator so
there are people just other than the
resident getting this notice there his
case Handler and everybody else is
getting getting that notice to be able
to act on it on the resident's behalf so
I I guess you know it doesn't seem
unreasonable to say to take that that
last line in number six that says then
include the rights of the resident to
appeal and add that to the 90-day notice
so that they know in advance as an
appeal process
and they're not waiting to just three
days before to find out there's an
appeal process
does that sound like a reasonable
compromise yes okay representative if I
could if I could follow up I think also
would that also be required would you be
looking for that in number four as well
number four is where a 72-hour notice is
given if they're
um behavior is dangerous so you're
saying in both of those places that's a
good idea representative Leo um thank
you madam chair my question is a little
more process related it sounds like
there's going to be significant changes
to this are we going to have a chance to
review that again before our final
approval because I would like to be able
to to compare what happens with the
general community and in those with
that are under the Bureau of
Developmental Services actually unless
there are some other issues
this one we've got some fairly specific
language we want to include in two known
places so that would be a conditional
approval if we were to approve and
that'll come back to us actually it
won't come back to us
um I guess my question is I would like
to be able to go a little deeper just to
make sure there's nothing else we're
missing that's provided to your average
person that's not provided here I'm just
not sure what that would do to our
process
that's another question
which timeline for us we our deadline is
May 20 23rd when's the next meeting
it would be before that okay
all right we will are there any other
questions or concerns specific
all right thank you
um
Excuse Me Miss Patrick
okay
all right so we will ask you to include
those items in a
um
for prior to conditional approval and we
will take it up at our next meeting to
give the committee a chance to to finish
reading this rule so are you postponing
this to the next meeting yes okay the
decision
you need a motion of that can we just do
it
um do we need a motion to postpone
it would be helpful I move the postpone
uh 12 seconds
by Leon and hack and Phillips uh any
those in favor
aye aye opposed all right we will see
this one again
all right uh case management agencies
who has that one uh 241
um yes this is the case management
agencies and I also did not have any
comments on this
okay is um are there any questions
I have a couple good
um
last year we found out there are
multiple definitions of case manager and
does this conflict with any of them or
does it specify exactly what type of
case manager is covered
foreign
so this is the licensing requirements
for for All Case Management agencies
um
in areas of Sanitation organization
Administration
physical environment health and safety
nursing Services resident environment
dietary needs medical records
um
I had no comments all right
I have a question yes for the so
essentially what this licensing
requirement does is combines all the
definitions of this is how I interpreted
it that it combines all the definitions
of case management agencies under one
is that right or no I don't believe so
no it's a an amendment
uh it's a re-adoption and with Amendment
oh I see okay yeah
um okay last um
last year when we're talking about it
there are multiple types of case
management
is which type is does this cover
General all-purpose case management
independent of providers
it's the licensing of the agency the the
case management agency all right so it's
like the whole business correct yeah
all right
um and this is and I
hello again
hello good morning Allison radmay
administrator for the administrative
rules unit for the Department of Health
and Human Services mind that's a moment
good morning I'm Kelly Keith licensing
for health facility Administration
and I'm
curious why you consider a case
management agency to be a facility
it's um in RSA 151 it's described as an
entity it's actually under the Home
Health agencies and that is required to
be licensed through 151.
okay but nothing okay go on
it's a requirement for the Department to
license these um
these case management agencies just as
we would any other
yes but something like
sanitation and physical environment I
mean you're
if you're talking about a case
management agency it doesn't actually
have residence I would imagine
is that correct
it seems like you're you're conflating
it with something much bigger than what
I assume a case management agency is
I guess I'm unclear
um or it's unclear are you looking at
the notice yes yes
maybe you could start by telling us can
you define what a case management
management agency is that might be
helpful because yes what is that what
does that mean case management agency
good morning for the record my name is
Dorian Shockley I am the manager of the
Bureau of Licensing and certification at
the Department of Health and Human
Services
earlier this year or last year it's hard
to keep track
RSA 151 was changed to include case
management agencies as part I don't have
that legislation in front of me the
definition in the rule for case
management agencies is
oh please it's on page two letter i
a case management agency means an
organization and consultation with the
client in the client's place of
residence arranges for and coordinates
the delivery of care and services to
meet the physical emotional medical
nursing Financial legal and social
services needs of the client
the rule further describes and defines
case manager case management supervision
and all of those requirements for those
that are being licensed to your comment
chairman McGuire chairwoman McGuire
there are many definitions within the
state of New Hampshire regarding case
managers there are many for personal
care assistance there are I mean there
are many definitions period in the state
of New Hampshire that are inconsistent
in rules and in law I think it is the
Department's overall goal to work
collaboratively across the agency to
make sure that there is consistency
we worked very closely with the
community of providers that are licensed
Incorporated and their input so we
believe that this is consistent with
what the
standard definition is there could still
be inconsistencies with some rules that
we're unaware of but to our knowledge
we've Incorporated all of those
is this consistent with your correction
corrective action plan to separate case
management from service providers so
that's not a question I can answer but I
have colleagues here that that doesn't
fall under our Bureau that falls under a
different Bureau
um Melissa Nemeth can speak to that
again again my name is Melissa nemes
with the attorney for the Bureau of
Developmental services and we do not see
any conflict between this Rule and the
corrective action plan thank you
seems decisive representative Leon thank
you madam chair and actually I have
another question that you may be the
right answer for Melissa my question is
there are concerns that this may be
um be a violation of the conflict of
interest so I was curious about the
status of the department waiver to
continue our conflict the labor of
conflict-free case management so the
department is under a corrective action
plan with with CMS to ensure that there
is conflict-free case management and our
deadline for compliance with that is uh
July 1st of this year and we believe
that we're on track this rule actually
is I think not doesn't really impact
that process because there are a variety
of other rules and and some preview of
Coming Attractions you'll see several of
them coming that work on the the all the
corrective action plan that the
department is under
um but this rule specifically doesn't
really touch on that we the choice and
the assurance that people get their free
choice of a provider is covered in those
other rules versus this rule
so would I be correct to understand that
the sorry is a follow-up would I be
correct to understand that the
department did not seek a waiver to
extend that deadline as I was under the
impression the department was going to
do that my understanding is that there
is no waiver being sought for the
deadline of July 1st to comply with
conflict-free case management there are
a variety of other initiatives that are
going on that fall outside of the
corrective action plan but I it it is
not my knowledge that the department is
seeking to waive that July 1st deadline
okay thanks good to know any other
questions
concerns all right thank you very much
Emily Johnson
thank you madam chair members of the
committee you have to speak into the
microphone
thank you madam chair members of the
committee I'm Emily Johnson with granite
case management thanks for hearing my
testimony this morning it's um
in um
Carolyn virtue from Granite case
management was able to work together
with the Department
um
and had the opportunity to submit
um her comments to them and I think we
were generally happy with 819
however the issues that were raised
earlier by this committee regarding
um
regarding concerns of conflict of
interest and the current
corrective action plan that New
Hampshire is under we believe that the
scope 81902 and I did hand out
um
I have some testimony and some
attachments which I think were emailed
to you earlier this morning
so I just will highlight
briefly here what our concerns are
in 819
um
in 81902c
uh we have a concern
regarding that language that all
licensed Health Care entities
um
whether residential or non-residential
where case management is a component of
the services provided to include but not
limited to hospitals nursing homes Home
Health agencies
assisted living facilities resident
Rehabilitation residential psychiatric
treatment substance use disorder
residential facilities non-emergency
walk-in Care Centers ambulatory surgical
centers and Stage renal dialysis centers
Community residences Adult Day Care
Centers yeah
you're signing
Hep 81901c
the version that we have
Hep
819.01 has no subsections
so that doesn't appear to be in the
final version
802 yes
81902 oh so it's a typo in your in your
written testimony
which refers to 8081901
I know and I'm sorry just I read that
entire thing for you so um anyway so our
our issue with that
um is just that understate and federal
regulations
case management is provided in these
settings as part of the Continuum of
Care
so those those entities are not case
managers
well correct that would be that would be
the idea
um and case management
we do case management under CFI right
um we are we work with the choices for
Independence waiver and we provide case
management in these uh in all of these
facilities so
um and I did cite some law here for you
regarding targeted case management
that excuse me
requires case management to be
accessible to all individuals who
require or are risk of requiring Nursing
Facility level of care
I'm reading all over the place I'm sorry
um so
this uh this would include patients in
these facilities that are listed in
81902 C
M okay so those entities by that rule
are Exempted from the
um this from this rule yeah from
licensure requirement
okay
questions representative Schmidt you
have a question they're indicating that
they just
all right yes thank you in that case
we'll go on to is that your major
concern
no
so the major concern would be
81902e and 819 o2f
um which we believe
um
allow for a conflict of interest in case
management
um and that it goes against what CMS
requires federal regulations and state
statutes regarding case management and
the requirement that case management be
delivered separate from
other services so if you're allowing for
um you're allowing for area agencies
um
as listed here under e
or all entities providing Service
Coordination to individuals receiving
developmental Disability Services
required brain disorder services and
you're exempting them from this rule
then you're allowing those entities and
area agencies to provide case management
in coordination with other services
which is exactly what New Hampshire is
dealing with right now under the
corrective action plan with CMS
so I have attached to this testimony a
copy of
the corrective action plan template and
I apologize I believe I only had two
copies of that and the rest of the
committee members should be in your
email
um there's a lot of paper to print out
this morning so I did attach that and
that's that's the issue that we're
dealing with right now under different
waivers so I fear that if you're going
to put this into law
we'd be creating an issue
because it's it's inconsistent with the
Federal Regulations so I would say
through all of this those are really our
major concerns
um okay so so your major concern is the
scope of the rules other than any of the
details further down correct okay thank
you that helps a little
Madam chairman Senator uh
Senator Lang so again so I think your
your problem is the Case Management
Services and the Direct Services need to
be separate is what you're saying in
this role right and they're not
according to this they could be combined
into the same agency and that's
problematic exactly thank you okay
all right uh thank you
Mr plank hey Madam chair thank you
Robert click for the record I just
wanted to point out somebody made
mention of the the law last year it was
Senate Bill 333 and it added um
including a Case Management Service
provided to a home health care provider
and and that's I believe what the the
Department was referencing before I just
want to make sure everybody knew which
one it was okay
all right um
did that bill become law yes and it was
a bipartisan bill I recall the testimony
and the issue very well I just want to
make sure it became okay thank you
representative
thank you madam chair that's my question
here is
um I'm not sure if you're the right
people to answer it but my question is
um are these case managers being carved
out separate from all of these other
entities that are licensed just so that
there's a license on the case managers
who would not otherwise come underneath
the scope of oplc
um
it's a good question it looks more to me
as though they are exempting
case managers in area agents there's
already an existing scope and they're
taking people out of the scope
we would agree with that what they're
doing is they're allowing people to be
unlicensed and do the case management
work is the way we read the rule that
they're trying to implement and I'd like
to ask the agency why they think it is
not a conflict of interest for entities
area agencies where case management is a
component of the services provided that
seems to me to be clearly a conflict of
interest
and the same look that in D and E
and the future could you explain that to
me please I'm I'm not a lawyer but would
you like us thank you
good morning again
so in the scope uh letter e well letter
e what used to be letter
um f it looks like area agencies were
always exempt from the licensure um if
they were providing case management and
the we've added the entities providing
service coordination and the reason we
don't think that this creates a problem
with the conflict is there is a separate
set of rules that govern
um the qualifications of service
coordinators and we think that it's
important that it not be
captured here it's not that there should
not be
oversight or any assurances that they
are following all of the Federal
Regulations it's just that this
particular rule did not seem to be the
vehicle to have that included
um we it cannot be the same agency that
provides case management as provides the
direct service there is a very limited
exception to that that has been approved
by CMS that there's already a process
for that and in the rules that are going
to be as I said before There Are Rules
coming before you we already have rules
around service coordinators in for
developmental Services
Service Coordination is the term that is
used for the person that
literally coordinates all the services
for individuals and because it is a
nuanced
set of services that are delivered and
there are requirements in addition to
what might be under 819 for what they
need to do the department feels it's
important to keep them in in their own
rules but have the appropriate oversight
um so that as I said the department does
not see this as any
indication that we are not following the
corrective action plan it's just that
those particular
folks providing Service Coordination to
this population
are better suited to fall under another
Rule and have their oversight provided
there I
um I take it those are the Hem 403 and
505 rules um 503 and 505 yes well then
there's a typo in Europe oh 403 I'm
sorry that's that letter D doesn't apply
that's for Community Mental Health
Centers
um so we're not talking about that here
um AGM 505 is for area agencies hem 503
is kind of the general rule for folks
entering the developmental Services
System and AGM 522 is the rules for
folks getting services for an acquired
brain disorder
okay and
represented so can I just make sure that
I'm understanding what you're saying so
you're saying that all the the various
agencies or service providers that would
be Exempted
from 819.02
are covered by other
uh provisions of of your of law or
regulations and those other provisions
of law regulations also contain
whatever conflict of interest uh uh
Provisions they need to contain so that
you're not in violation of federal law
is that is that correct that's exactly
correct all right thank you
I think these these rules could be
worded a little more clearly because as
I read d and e it sounds as though the
mental health program or the area agency
is providing case management and other
services which you say is a which seems
like a correct a conflict of interest to
me
under uh so I can't the Community Mental
Health Centers don't fall under the
corrective action plan but for the area
agencies they actually are able to
provide both types of services it just
cannot be to the same person so they
could provide me with case management
and Doreen with Service Coordination but
they couldn't provide me with both
direct service and Service Coordination
it's
I repeat that it could be a lot clearer
that that's the case
because it it doesn't read that way at
least not to me
representative fellows yes I'm just
wondering if do other states use the
same
um
definitions and do they use service
coordinator and case management to
describe the different roles areas New
Hampshire may be different from other
states I I don't know specifically I
know that under the federal regulations
for the waivers that we operate under
they actually make it clear in their
guidance that the function of case
management might be called Service
Coordination or something else so it's
definitely permissible I don't know
specifically what other states do
any other comments questions
yeah so we have we have time on this
rule so I I guess what I'd say is I
think it's probably appropriate we
postpone this and let until next month
let them rewrite that section and make
it a little more clearer and cleaner so
that it's obvious to what that we don't
have any of these conflicts that
everyone's talking about yes because
since we have been
essentially caught with conflicts of
interest and we're working on resolving
them I think it would be better if we're
clearer like you say that the area
agencies you know don't provide case
management and services to the same
people
this has a motion to postpone yes
representative director Morrow
um
if the committee is requesting the
agency to modify the language it has to
be done either through a conditional
approval or a preliminary objection with
a conditional approval the language
needs to be specific in that case a
thing a preliminary objection would be
in order
so moved
okay that would be based on Clarity yes
and public testimony
they pointed out the
okay
any other questions
comments all right those in favor of a
preliminary objection I I opposed
all right thank you we'll see what we
can do about that one
all right
Respiratory Care practitioners okay yes
ma'am um this proposal would adopt
irregular rules um that are currently
interim rules which are scheduled to
expire on May 23rd so next month
um there are a couple of issues uh one
the committee has actually heard about
before and that's on page eight of the a
PDF document and that's around the
retention schedule issue and like I said
we've discussed that before and my
understanding is there's currently some
legislation that would um address that
issue so I wasn't going to spend a lot
of time on that the second issue is that
there has been some testimonies
submitted and you do have that at the
tail end of your packet and that
testimony is on the fact that the rules
do not address the licensing of student
interns but RSA 541a 22 Roman numeral 3
B does require specific Authority to
issue licenses so an agency needs to
have specific authority to be able to do
that and the Respiratory Care statute
doesn't have any language whatsoever on
interns or students not their scope of
practice nothing on licensing
requirements just nothing
so um so it looks like there's some need
for possibly for some legislation to
address that issue but again there are
some people here who have submitted
cards and would like to testify on that
and with that I I don't have any
additional comment okay
Christy Baker
yes please
do you want me to address any of the
comments or would you like to let's hear
the comments of
um
got it let's do the comments first and
then we'll take the public testimony
director Mike
you have not turned on
I turn it on then I turn it off I
apologize uh for the record Lindsay
Courtney executive director oplc
um with respect to the retention
schedule issue I think this issue has
probably been discussed before
um we did go through the Secretary of
State's office took about a year to get
approval what is posted on our website
is the format that they sent back to me
I recognize that it may require
additional Clarity but did not feel that
it was within our purview to deviate
from what was approved by the Secretary
of State's office additionally I do not
believe that oplc has rulemaking
authority over retention schedules
rather our statute requires us to adopt
a policy in accordance with the
secretary of state requirements
Secretary of State obviously needs to
conduct rulemaking and once that is done
we will be sure to follow those
regulatory requirements with respect to
the student licensure issue we have
thoroughly reviewed this from a legal
standpoint with multiple attorneys in
the office my understanding is that and
I'm sure you will and I defer to others
to explain the basis for it I have no
objection to the policy reasons why we
would may want to consider licensure
students my understanding is it's it's
really from a reimbursement standpoint
but our position is that we do not have
legal authority to do so
um we considered uh maybe seeking
legislation this past session but given
the climate of licensure changes did not
think that this was the right session to
do so and therefore happy to regroup
with stakeholders and or legislators for
next session if that is desirable but
from a policy standpoint did not believe
that this was the right opportunity to
bring this up
questions for the director
seeing them thank you okay so uh
are you together sir
ma'am
more or less
all right
please my name is Christy Baker I
believe and I am a respiratory therapist
within the state of New Hampshire and I
remember
I'm sorry I have a soft voice anyway
um my name is Christy Baker Epley and I
represent respiratory therapy
um I am on The Advisory Board a new
member so I'm not exactly
good at how this whole process works uh
I had asked a couple of other members of
respiratory therapy within our state so
I have there's three of us here today to
represent student licensure and a few
other questions that we had
um
this is Patrick Montano going to start
sure
hi so my name is Patrick I'm a
respiratory therapist
um before we go into the student
licensure section that I had a lot of
questions regarding verbage and wording
of this and it became clear to me that
um respiratory therapists weren't
involved in the creation of these rules
so when I reached out to people on from
The Advisory Board who I know I asked
them if they were involved in the OR
vetting these rules and they told me
they were not so I don't know if that is
accurate or not but there are a lot of
questions regarding education
requirements what is able to be used for
continuing education credits when I
wrote reached out to oplc to ask them
for clarification specifically with a
certain um
1507.07a asking with Healthcare
leadership classes could be considered
for that rule they told me it depends on
if it's covered by the rule or not was
the answer I got so
um I'm not sure if this has been fully
vetted and I guess that's why I'm asking
you guys to postpone the approval here
as far as Respiratory Care licensure for
students okay right so
um
so you're concerned about the
continuing education requirements yeah a
lot of the continu they were vague to me
as what was accepted it was 1507 dot
sorry 1507.07 a
specifically I asked if Healthcare
leadership classes would be able to be
used for that and the oplc could not
tell me if they would accept that or not
okay it says they are either
all right
that does appear a little Vega who has
to approve them because any Statewide
Professional Organization sounds
okay
um
than
1507.09 a there is other examinations
that are very relevant to the profession
of Respiratory Care higher Level
examinations such as the ECMO also has a
e a e Dash aec certification which is uh
extraordial membrane oxygenation
certification which is a higher end
therapy that would be relevant here that
is left off
so a bunch of questions about that and
that's when I got into the fact that you
know The Advisory Board wasn't consulted
in these rules okay that's concerning
as far as student licensures go I guess
the one of the questions I have about
student licensure is actually
1506.02 actually talks about student
interns
specifically so I'm not sure they're not
licensed interns but it comments on that
1506.
O2
internship allowed okay
okay it specifically says that a person
may be
may work as an intern without a license
if you're enrolled in a program to
educate that meets the requirements of
the
um so the vacation areas are we allowed
to pay these interns are they allowed to
perform independently or are these
actually just student
internships where they are actually
supervised it's not clear uh that
doesn't appear to deny independent
practice
okay that was not how I read it it says
may engage inactive normally undertaken
by a
Uh I that does appear to be a little
vague okay and then as far as
um so that's kind of what brought me
into thinking that student licensure
would be able to be approved by the RSA
and possibly it's not but I just want to
put a little bit of the scope of the
problem of Respiratory Care so while you
know you've heard about Healthcare
shortages nationally nursing programs
are fully enrolled right they are filled
Radiology programs are filled currently
hospitals or the larger hospitals that
we represent are about 30 percent down
with our employment
enrollment in RT programs is down 63
nationally so that's 63 vacancies
including our local Claremont program of
that we are expected to grow 14 in the
next 10 years
of the students that are in the
Claremont program most of them are
getting student jobs in Vermont because
they're right on the border and then
when they're graduating they're actually
going to work in Vermont instead of New
Hampshire hospitals because they've
already built a relationship with their
employers there
and could you explain why they're
working in Vermont rather than New
Hampshire because in Vermont they're
allowed to work as student respiratory
therapists and get paid
this yeah okay so they don't uh Vermont
actually Maine and Massachusetts all
have student rules we're the only one
that doesn't Okay and and it is assumed
that an internship means there's no pick
that is my understanding okay thank you
that's I don't believe that's always the
case but if that's what people assume
that's uh yeah I would love to hear
otherwise
yes so I'm I'm guilty of being Married
to Medicine so
um yes I think it's kind of an industry
practice that if you're in an internship
in a hospital or Healthcare setting that
you are receiving compensation for that
pay or that that labor so even if it is
supervised learning
um that there is a lot of work that goes
into that so okay I think
proposing to train someone without
paying them it seems really unreasonable
it's not competitive that's for
sure right well we can't skip the
statutory requirement that we have to
have approval for that license
but
um
it's like it's my ask of the committee
and you can speak after I'm done sorry
uh would be that you would propose
postpone these roles and ask the oplc to
involve the Respiratory Care Advisory
Board in re-working them and making sure
that the veganies have been made clear
right okay
um Madam chair yes the interim rules
expire on May 23rd the committee is
meeting on May 19th so that's pretty
tight you could do a preliminary
objection but
um again you know the the interim rules
will expire
um
on the 20th we're meeting on the 19th
right
I think the we that should allow us time
to get a little Clarity on your other
questions
about the Education and Training the
part about the student licenses we can't
solve immediately so we let's not worry
about it for the time being
um even we'll if we can think of
something that might allow it
I think one and as far as the the
clarification on the internship if
they're allowed to work I guess the
clarification I would be seeking is are
they allowed to work independently and
are they allowed to be paid
the independent part certainly could be
clarified and
uh actually the pay too I mean I don't
see why it it should be mandatory that
they're not paid
right I think our historical assumption
is that has been for students who come
from education programs and that is
while they're with us doing their
clinical time
okay well it sounds like a number of
clarity issues that the Board needs to
be more involved in would a uh do we
need to give a preliminary objection or
should we just postpone the decision you
could postpone
um one other issue I was going to um
just highlight is that in the definition
of Respiratory Care in the statute there
is the concept of supervision of a less
skilled person in Respiratory Care but
really that's the only place where where
you could kind of highlight there being
a student or somebody not qualified to
perform Respiratory Care unlicensed
right
just so whatever so I pulled up the the
exemption licensure statute and it does
say in there that it says related to a
person's Respiratory Care education
while under the direct supervision of a
respiratory care practitioner or
physician so in the RSA itself it
defines that a person working under
there well they don't have to be
licensed they do have to be working
under the direct
supervision of a respiratory care
practitioner or physician
if I may Madam chair I would like to
address the notice issue
so these rules are largely based on the
interim rules which obviously went
through notice procedure which were
largely based on the prior rules we did
not receive a lot of feedback during the
interim rule making but we did receive
feedback after the fact and I do believe
that these rules went through an
advanced public comment period meaning
that we we requested it comments prior
to initiating a formal rulemaking we did
receive significant comments
particularly on the issue as it relates
to equipment because previously under
the prior rules one had to be licensed
in order to basically manage and install
equipment so we've responded to those
comments and you can see that at the end
of our filing
I I take issue with the representation
that we did not seek stakeholder input
if you look at our
websites all of the Respiratory Care
meetings in 2022 were canceled we are
happy to work with stakeholders moving
forward on these issues including
seeking a statutory change but given
that the interim rules are about to
expire do not believe that it's in the
best position for licensees that we
postpone these rules rather I'd like
them to go forward and then we can
re-initiate rulemaking if necessary with
additional stakeholder input
so I
have questions yes so can I can I just
uh am I understanding what what you're
basically saying is that that although
the people we heard from a moment ago
are kind of complaining now they had
plenty of opportunity to have their
input and they didn't take advantage of
it then is that what you're saying
yes and I think we can always do more
communication but the fact that we
communicated is supported by the fact
that people did provide comments that we
responded to as is listed in your packet
as well
does someone have motion
I'm chair I'm going to move to a proof
and I'd like to speak to my motion when
I'm done all right is there a second
second
so again I I think the combination on
the student licensing it's clear that
there is no provision for oplc to issue
a license or create they can't create a
license out of thin air unless
authorized by the legislature so there's
nothing they can do to create a
licensure that would allow an intern or
student to act and the statute's clear
that they have to act in the
supervisions I don't know that there's
any necessary Clarity that's needed
there unless for some reason we want to
license them but
um as to the
um
the continuing education requirements
and those conditions again I I think the
agency's been clear that they are more
than willing to reopen rule making but
the interim rules are about to expire we
need to move forward so that the license
the rule itself doesn't expire any and
the profession is injured or harmed
representative Schmidt actually
representative Lynn can speak to a
second first so you know I agree with
everything that Senator Lang said the
only thing I would say is
um uh well it while the statute that he
read I think does make it clear that
they that the the uh a student needs to
be operating under the direct
supervision of a licensee I'm not sure
that there's anything in the law unless
there's another provision that hasn't
been referred to that would prevent a
student from being paid
um and so I think that's something that
uh I'm not sure that that would even
need to necessarily be covered by uh by
regulation I think it's just up to the
you know the the employer to decide
whether they want to pay somebody and it
probably it sounds like given what the
competitive situation that it might make
sense to start paying them but uh I
don't know that we need a regulation for
that so anyway I I but I I agree with
Senator Lang's comments completely
thank you and I agree with the previous
speaker's statement
and would the senator uh
consider amending his motion uh slightly
to encourage uh further legislative
further legislation because it seems to
me like the statute could be improved
but I agree with your characterization
of what we have before us now
so again I I I'm sure Mike made a list
of legislative recommendations and
changes and I don't necessarily know it
needs to be an emotion itself
yeah so I I would think it would
probably be better
I mean to If a person is
a student but wants to be paid they
could be paid as some sort of medical
technician
and work under the direct supervision of
a uh of a licensed practitioner which I
hope is the case
because the intern is allowed to to work
into without direct supervision so I
would think that if you're trying to get
on the job experience
for yours for the sake of the profession
you would not want to just say oh here
you act like a respiratory therapist
director uh Madam chairman
based on personal belief uh I I think
it's common that interns would be paid
but I think uh one factor in that maybe
the educational institution that the
student is at I understand it in some
instances if the internship is going to
if the intern is going to receive credit
from the school the school may say you
cannot be paid
ah okay well that's
if that's the case then that's up to the
school to consider if that's affecting
the uh but there is no Prohibition in
the rule itself from the individuals
being paid
yeah I know
ages ago when uh when I worked as an
intern I got paid very well
that was a long long time ago
so I I just um before we have emotion
I'm just I have a question about the can
the comment that the continuing
education section was vague is that
going to be addressed
uh I would it sounded to me as though it
was more incomplete and
it director Courtney is there a way for
the board to add additional
courses
for continuing education approval
I think that the um the requirements are
intended to be fairly broad so that
um more courses can meet the
requirements I think part of the issue
we run into when people ask us questions
like would this qualify without having
the course before us we can't really say
you know conduct an analysis as to
whether or not it would meet those
regulatory requirements and we're not
really in a position to be giving legal
advice in advance of reviewing that
um
um before you know before it's submitted
so I think that
um Our advice to words is typically to
keep it you know fairly broad to capture
all of the types of continuing education
that you think could fulfill those
applications rather than creating
discrete categories that would exclude
things you might otherwise think as
valuable education but you can approve
yeah non-specifically listed courses yes
correct okay good that's the important
thing thank you I'd like to mention to
the therapists that these rules are
normally written by lawyers and they do
things differently than the rest of us
so
if you have specific courses you want to
get approved that's
sound like that you should go ahead and
ask for them to be included
any other comments questions
okay in that case we have a motion to
approve
those in favor
aye opposed
all right thank you very much
all right on to the Department of Safety
um so this is an interim Rule and for
the newer committee members that means
that if it is approved it will be valid
only for 180 days to allow the agency to
engage in the regular rulemaking process
this is a straight adoption of a new
section uh
safe the 9100 section on the rules for
Carriage of household goods by Motor
Vehicles this is in result to a new
statute are say 359 T
that statute actually encompasses some
of the prior requirements that were
under RSA 375a but 375a was repealed
when this new statute went into effect
um so a number of the comments um on the
interim rule can be addressed during the
rulemaking process
um but at this time
um we want to bring it up now so that it
can be addressed in the regular rule
making process or if the committee
determines that they're too big of an
issues that they need to be addressed um
before that
so the first issue is actually a note to
GL car on the top of page one of the
rule so because there was a previous
statute with similar requirement or
similar language the agency already had
some rules in place under 4 600 that
they used
most of the language for some of the
rule requirements under 4600 are
identical or very similar to what is now
going to be 9100 but at this time the 4
600 rules there's still an effect so
would they have been repealed and when
the statute was repealed there as far as
I could see there was no language in the
statute the repeal of the statute or the
um new statute that resulted in those
rules becoming non-effective and because
they have the authority now under five
359 T which I said are pretty much
similar that that would transfer to that
statute
um so there is a bit of a
issue of which rules are going to be
effective if the 9100s come are approved
today you have two sets of rules that
are effective at the same time
um so perhaps the agency can discuss if
they have plans to address that or maybe
come up with a plan to address that
the second substantive comment is on
page three of the rule text it's under
the part titled estimates
um
the rules specifically states that the
carrier shall not charge the customer
any amount which exceeds 10 without the
customer's written consent
however it's unclear from the rules face
what that 10 is based off of it may be
inferred that the agency intends it to
be based on the estimate but with regard
to the standards the rule making that's
not
clear enough it should be they should be
stating what exactly that 10 is going to
be based upon
the next comment is on page four of the
rule text that section regards voluntary
suspensions the role text is not clear
on what the department will consider
when determining if they will allow a
carrier to voluntarily suspend its
certificate or permit whether the agency
is going to just automatically Grant it
as soon as they get the request or if
there's going to be criteria that
they're going to be considering
additionally it's not clear when they
will make this determination especially
if there's an ongoing adjudicatory
process because the under these rules
the agency can also revoke a carrier's
permit or certificate after the
adjudicatory process has completed so if
a carrier
puts in a request to voluntarily suspend
after
the hearing has already
finished and the department is
considering whether to revoke how are
they going to determine if they're
revoking or voluntarily suspending
uh the next couple of comments have to
do with the agency's forms there are
three forms that are uh that accompany
this particular rule
um and none of them are Incorporated by
reference so a majority of the comments
have to do with inconsistencies between
the forms and the rule text and I can go
into the specific comments that the
committee wants no no because the
inconsistencies between the form and the
rule are the kind of thing I expect them
to deal with in regular rulemaking okay
so that would be the remainder of my
comments okay
thank you
hey good morning Aaron Johnson uh
administrative rules coordinator with
the Department of Safety uh for the
first comment addressing the fact that
we're going to have two different uh
sets of rules in place uh it's the
Department's understanding that it is
unclear based off of the uh the bill
that had passed whether or not the 4600s
are still in effect so our goal is to
put the 9100s into um interim rules and
we've actually gained a lot of comments
just from OLS over this you know that we
want to address in the 4600s which uh we
will continue doing that with regular
rulemaking under the 4600s based off of
the approval of the 9100s but it sounds
like you're going backwards yeah isn't
the 9100s the new rules they are the new
rules for interim and we intend to adopt
the regular rules under the 4600s we
just wanted the interim rules in place
while we
figure out how to address the 4600s with
the regular rulemaking
okay is anyone else confused so uh we
yeah I guess to kind of clarify uh we we
weren't sure whether or not the 4600s
really did have any effect and we're
still working on drafting the language
for the regular rulemaking so we decided
to do the interim rules under 9100
because if let's say we get these
adopted and we have six months if we
don't adopt the regular rules within
that six month period then that would
essentially Wipe Out the interim rules
and then the regular rules would
disappear as well and since we're
unclear whether or not we still have
Authority Under the 4600s we we want to
reserve the right to be able to revert
back in the in the instance that we
don't have the regular rulemaking
finalized
ah so the that's not the normal PC so
you're putting these these rules in as a
six-month temporary rule to cover the
fact that you're going to be making
changes in the other rules about
about carriers is that correct correct
okay
uh if there is a conflict between the
two sets of rules which takes precedence
the Department's going to take uh the
9100s as precedent
then I would strongly recommend that you
add that in case of conflict with the
4600 rules these rules apply okay the
department that definitely needs to be
added to the rule
okay anyone else representative
um
I would suggest that in hindsight the
thing to do if this was to implement new
legislation that the appropriate thing
was to amend
um 4600 through an interim rule I do
understand that the question was about
the validity up and I mean if the
statute that was that
4600 Implement has
gone away then I think there could be a
presumption that 4 600 is not
enforceable anymore
I know it's a rather unusual instance
here where there's a similar statute
that's going to apply but it seems like
they should just have should have just
done 4 600 again or as they could as
part of the regular rulemaking repeal
4600 and have everything in 9100.
that would be
would make it clear where the authority
is but
I think our request is that you figure
out what the permanent
rule is what the Authority for it is and
make it clear to everybody because
you've got the whole room full of people
confused
Center so again I'm assuming the agency
is okay with adding to 9101 or 9100 that
language that 9100 takes precedent over
4 600 if there is a conflict because
we're still unsure which whether 4600 is
a valid but if there is a conflict and
it's determined it is valid that 9100 is
the precedent not or the standard not
4600 are you okay with that edit to the
existing interim rule yes we are okay
and I think the question about the
10 again
yes so that is going to be 10 of the
original estimate that a household
carrier uh would provide to the customer
before signing a contract so we'll we'll
just need to add that language in there
to specify that it's of the original
estimate and that's something no that's
actually it's going to be 110 of the
original estimate I guess 110 of the
original estimate okay
so
move to conditionally approved
is there a second
any further comments questions
discussion
okay not seeing any
those in favor
aye aye
those opposed
no one thank you very much and uh good
luck with your rulemaking
yes
it's from all of us I think whichever
room it is
there any other business
no Madam chairman we could uh determine
to eliminate the continued meeting
I believe that would would make sense
yes no continued meeting in that case
unless there's an objection we'll
adjourn
ing just to say that